water convocó reunió e incitó a la turba
que irrumpió en el capitolio el mes
pasado luego se deleitó con la victoria
que siguió ese fue el punto central de
la fiscalía en el segundo juicio
político a trump haciendo referencia a
la obra hamlet de shakespeare el
principal abogado de la acusación
demócrata dijo que si bien la violencia
atestiguada en washington puede haber
parecido a un caos había método en la
locura
la evidencia le mostrará que el
expresidente trump no era un espectador
inocente ilusión mostrará quedamos anp
renunció a su papel de comandante en
jefe y se convirtió en incitador en jefe
de una peligrosa insurrección de interés
instrucción se espera que los demócratas
pasen dos días intentando mostrar como
trump pasó semanas alentando a sus
partidarios a rechazar los resultados de
las elecciones presidenciales de
noviembre que tachó de fraudulentas lo
que sentó las bases para los disturbios
de enero
se ha expuesto una gran cantidad de
imágenes de los disturbios
[Música]
así como capturas de pantalla de los
tweets de trump y extractos de sus
discursos y tienes que hacer que tu
gente luche luchamos como el infierno y
si no luchan como el infierno ya no
tendrán un país y tienes que hacer que
tu gente luche les dijo que era parte de
un esfuerzo de meses cuidadosamente
planeado con una instrucción muy
específica en scratch
preséntate el 6 de enero y haz que tu
gente peleé contra la certificación
fighter dedication a diferencia del
primer juicio político a trump en enero
del año pasado se espera que esté
concluya rápidamente se necesitan 67
votos para condenar al ex presidente
esto implica que 17 republicanos
tendrían que unirse a las filas
demócratas algo que parece improbable